if you're looking to stand out from the
crowd this summer just ask christian
conte and matthias copper
they belong to a group of five designers
who call themselves cowboys they make
sunglasses
from natural wood
did they come on we got the idea
traveling through central america i went
there with a friend and we went to lots
of craft markets
we saw many different ways of doing
things with wood and thought to
ourselves let's do something else
the sunglasses are modelled on design
classics and made of tropical wood
they have names like ustus ferdinand
leopold and alfonse
the designers shun thick varnish to keep
the surfaces smooth
the young entrepreneurs set up their
company in 2012 their wooden sunglasses
are sold online and at 45 dealerships
across europe prices start at 139 euros
every tree is different so every pair of
our sunglasses is unique
the feel of the materials
knows all about wooden sunglasses and
everything else that's hot this summer
she's a consultant at a cologne
opticians advising on the latest eyewear
fashions
wooden glasses aren't all that easy to
make and they're not as easy to fit as
plastic frames
that's why it's important that they sit
perfectly right from the start and
anyone who knows wood knows it's
something unusual to have on your face
this is
it
nowadays these glasses are far from
unusual aviator sunglasses
originally they were made for american
military pilots but later gained cult
status and they're as wearable as ever
they differ in detail the difference is
that for ladies they have more features
so for example here you've got leather
in various colors
they're still big this year and some are
a bit more rounded
that makes them more streamlined i
for gentlemen they're a bit squarer they
usually prefer things that aren't too
playful
and another classic design the
round-shaped panto glasses of the 1920s
also this summer more and more people
are slipping on cat eye glasses or
butterfly shaped glasses the vintage
look is in
the cat eyebrows
the cat eye and butterfly glasses are
very new models and haven't been on the
market for long
any lady can wear them if she wants to
the cat eye glasses are more for narrow
faces
anyone can wear the butterfly glasses
color blocking is also a must right now
yellow purple
green or bright red the bolder the
better with color blocking anything goes
for me
i definitely like them because i have a
large head i choose a model that really
suits my face
and i like neon colors whatever's in
fashion right now
i think light colors are nice for the
summer like these that are a bit pearl
colored
they're colorful they're big they're
plastic modern but at the same time
i generally prefer sunglasses that are a
bit bigger so they cover half your face
my favorite sunglasses at the moment are
the ones i'm wearing aviator glasses i
find them really stylish
they're okay to go
for fans of the wooden variety the guys
from cowboys are already planning their
next collection alongside models in
exotic sobrano and sandalwood they'll be
turning to native germanwood for new
inspiration